so this whole like let's go back to the
[__] thing about they really think
low-income neighborhoods no no we're
only talking about gay alpha or Tommy
Oliver now yeah we're not we're staying
that ship has sailed hey hey it's morph
in time yeah dude we're talking about
Power Rangers
[Music]
so in um San Francisco apparently
after a board vote of eight to three the
police are now allowed to deploy robots
that are lethal
she said this has no information
so out of context Ryan what are you
talking about it was in the host chat
Ryan come on that was a host chat this
guy like Joe Rogan posted this and
everyone was like on his [__] because he
didn't read the actual like context
what's the actual context it doesn't
mean that like robots can kill people it
means that this is something they've
already done where like let's say
there's like a [__] guy taking a
bunch of kids hostage in a room right
there you can send in like a rolling
machine that has like something to like
either look at him or or it could have a
bomb to blow the wall up so they can get
in but then if if he were to die from
the actions of the robot it would he
wouldn't be able to like prosecute the
force oh that's right that's not a
killer robot I mean now there's
clearance for there's always been
clearance for that whose side are you on
bro yeah dude [__] robocops yeah
exactly that's how Skynet starts yeah
you sound like a rope the military robot
dogs with guns on top it looks like that
Black Mirror dog like identically but
there's so many articles where they're
just showing random robots not even the
[__] there is no robot that like they
didn't make one that kills people so the
robot can't use AI to Def decide for
itself whether or not to use the phone
no it's still uh control a human being
it's always a extension of a person
controlling kind of like a bomb diffuser
you know like the bomb diffusers or
sometimes robots that is weird that you
can't prosecute the person then because
the person you have the person that's
still control because it would be the
same as if like an actual like uh
policeman shot when they were designated
to shoot yeah it's the same thing it's
like oh the policeman was designated to
use this robot to take the criminal down
oh I see any means necessary yeah yeah
it's because technically they're playing
a game got it let's see just like the
drones is that correct how drone Pilots
are murderers yeah right
um so the San Francisco Police
Department said it does not have
pre-armed robots and has no plans to arm
robots with guns but the department
could deploy robots equipped with
explosive charges quote to contact
incapacitate or disorient violent armed
or dangerous suspects when lives are at
stake that sounds crazier but that's
also the same thing as just a regular
police officer like I can tase or shoot
you when you're presenting a record the
recent proposal so supervisors amended
The Proposal Tuesday to specify that
officers could use robots only after
using alternative force or de-escalation
tactics or concluding they would not be
able to subdue the suspect through those
alternative means only a limited number
of high-ranking officers could authorize
use of robots as a deadly force option
wow like in the situation of the school
shooter where he was like nobody wanted
to run in yeah it's like if they had a
[__] bot and they just had the bot
going
oh [__] that's kind of thing they could
have probably done something sooner no I
wanted to run it that's kind of gangster
then but at this point it's not like
they said they're not putting guns on
Bots that can like you know from a
computer Aim Shoot kill type stuff what
about poison darts oh my God be so sorry
that'd be sick dude and it comes out of
their mouth so they gotta go and it
looks like a [__] mouth what the [__]
that's a sex robot oh I think this
robot's about to suck myself I put my
gun down
whoa I feel you charge to take my [__]
out
it's a blow up doll dude all the kids
are like ew I want to see the weapons
conventional for this you know yeah dude
the the tech Dem would be hot I want to
see this Tech demo it would be sick to
have like a drone flying robot then you
wouldn't have all those [__]
high-speed chases oh yeah because then
if you're trying to drive away and this
thing goes
like right in front of you and just
points a gun at you like oh [__] I'm
gonna snow that all right all right take
the keys out yeah yeah I don't think
it's a necessarily a bad idea I think
it's just it's already being done it
just puts it in policy can't do Ryan's
watch you know what Singapore if my kid
was in school I'm like send 50 [__]
robots in there yeah dude yeah if it's
controlled by a guy that makes me feel
better like AI makes me feel I don't
want [__] like 20 [__] cops that
are like [__] just out of the fresh
out of the academy they're all scared I
know but after you saw that scene yeah
right they're standing for like 45
minutes send a [__] robot kid and
then the guy thinks he's got a kid
hostage and the head turns around goes
yeah yeah yeah
because we have that Tech already for
sure for sure dude
so opponents uh uh said the authority of
this would lead to further
militarization of a police force already
too aggressive with poor and minority
communities
you guys agree I always look I always
agree with anything slippery slope when
it comes to robots yeah
yeah I'm just on the team of like that's
a slippery slope but that's thinking if
they're running on autonomous AI right
yeah that's scary what if it's just a
[__] Power Glove was that the
headline originally that like it was an
AI power yeah that's the headline no
it's no it's about killing people you
think yeah I saw this I saw this clip
being posted I mean this uh this
screenshot being posted everywhere and I
remember seeing like AI yeah and it
looks like a battlebot from the [__]
show it says robots that kill robots
that will kill you and it's a picture of
the tournament when Joe Rogan posted it
like donut operator was in his comments
going like I thought out of anybody you
would have at least read the content
which is why I didn't read the title I
said robots with lethal yes capacity
appreciate that but yeah it's not these
like roving [__] like those delivery
cards that go around just now they're
cleared to kill you it's like humanoids
it's like you already have to be in the
situation of like hey take this guy down
with deadly force that deadly force
option just happens to be a robotic
device yeah that'd be tight I think I'm
I thought San Francisco would be like
celebrating this because it's genderless
dude yeah if there's a if it's a a gay
robot that kills
I think that would be that'd be gangster
it'd be kind of excited about it
gangster [__] I'd be tight it's like the
first gay robot that kills I know and
they should be celebrating that the
robot have like a certain type of Voice
or something or I don't know I think it
would just sound like a robot yeah
because that's what that's why do you
think it should what are you trying to
say okay
how would no my I should have phrase I
am allegedly gay yeah exactly how would
how would the robot identify themselves
again I think they would sound like a
serial number from Power Rangers
oh yeah Alpha was gay Alpha was gay he
was a gay Latin man nah Alpha got it in
with chicks all the time you think so
for sure yeah yeah yeah you want to
check out the command center you brought
him there when zordo was sleeping
he's like
what are you doing what are you doing
over there
over here this is where the Pink Ranger
sits and then he's like
[Laughter]
I think the biggest issue about San
Francisco isn't even this whole robot
thing but for a major city they close
too early
way too early I'm out there and I'm like
why do you guys close like you're a
small town you're a major city you guys
need to stay open later it's only
Chinese restaurants that are open at
night that's true and and bars that's it
can we go back to gay Alpha though yeah
almost lit dude the song about him
smelling Pink Rangers sitting here he's
smelling [__] green rangers [__]
see oh recipes
because he was the heartthrob everyone
[__] loved him Tommy Tommy Oliver
dude Tommy Oliver RP bro so sad so young
did they say how he went away he
committed suicide I think but did any
yeah did anybody all I said after that
once you try to look forward it uh
you're just talking about how the family
wants privacy and stuff like that but I
want to know I do so this whole like
let's go back to the [__] thing about
they really think low-income
neighborhoods I don't know we're only
talking about gay alpha or Tommy Oliver
now yeah we're not we're staying that
ship has sailed hey hey It's morphin
time yeah dude we're talking about Power
Rangers
I find it hard to believe that the
lowest income places would be would be
hit the hardest by the highest income
material
that's true the department can't afford
this [__] I know I guess maybe uh I
guess potentially the perspective that
um the police force in general like you
view it in one way right like it's just
if they are already like that then
whatever their accessories or their
tools would be administered to the same
perspective as all right so even if it's
not AI whoever's controlling it like the
guy who was willing to come in and
militarize a you know the minority
Community anyway because now he's just
in charge of a crazier toy that can be
an extension of his person statistically
speaking most people that are in a
situation where they've taken kids
hostage are probably low earners I'm
guessing and if it's not coming from
rich neighborhood yeah unless you're
Jeffrey it's not a [__] rich guy
doing that and then if it's in a San
Francisco stats are you're probably also
not a low owner but now you're using
like the data and facts and that's
you're making it too real Ryan like
can't you get on board with the board
that is funny because it's like what are
the poor people gonna do and it's like
wait where you guys gentrified the [__]
out of the city what poor people yeah
that's true because that mission area
all that [__] used to be ghetto has they
don't live in that stuff anymore it's
not it's gone what are they gonna start
doing a Robocop type of thing that's
tight half man half robots five dead cop
half dead cop Peter Weller [__] you know
what I mean which Park do you want to be
the man which part you want to be the
robot maybe I like RoboCop I like the I
like the this part was man
I thought it was cool dude the theme
song right here where his whole face
right I think there Joe wants the lips
he wants to throat the tongue in the
mouth what a coincidence yeah dude you
know why cool thanks Joe Joe's like I
want to make sure I can taste things
hey it's San Francisco all right when in
Rome like what a like heady discussion
we could have had and then Joe's would
be like I want the lips to be like a man
with the RoboCop theme song
up